MATT THOMAS: Hi, my name's Matt.
And I'm head of
foresight and insight
at the British Red Cross.
Cast your mind back
to March of 2020,
what now feels like
several lifetimes ago.
The COVID-19 pandemic was
starting to grip the world.
And the UK, where
I am, was entering
its first national lockdown.
The British Red Cross was in the
midst of planning our emergency
response.
We were gearing up to
deliver food parcels,
and deliver medicines,
support people
who were lonely, or
socially isolated,
and help people
who had been moved
into emergency accommodation.
But, how did we know
who needed support
and where we might find them?
The day before lockdown
began, I made our first commit
to what would become known
as the vulnerability index.
My colleague, Al, and I,
were rapidly designing a map
to model vulnerability
to COVID-19
in neighborhoods across the UK.
This map would be used to
plan not only the British Red
Cross's pandemic
response, would also
inform other voluntary and
community sector organizations,
as well as government
and public health bodies.
It needed to be expensive,
rigorous, and accurate.
And we needed to
build it quickly.
700 commits, more
than a hundred data
indicators, and
several new gray hairs
later, this is where we are now.
My team and I built a
set of open-source tools
that measured the vulnerability
of different geographical areas
of the UK and their
ability to cope.
Today, we have a suite of
dashboards, maps, and data sets
that anyone can use for free.
How did we get there?
We had to figure out
what makes people
vulnerable to the disease.
COVID-19 isn't just a
public health emergency.
It's also a social and
economic emergency.
And we needed to account
for vulnerability
in a multi-dimensional way.
We gathered data on over a
hundred indicators related
to people's clinical
vulnerability,
and socioeconomic vulnerability,
as well as their wider health
and well-being needs.
But, we had to find some
way to merge everything
into a single
vulnerability score,
and we needed to do it fast.
So I picked up the
phone and I called Mike.
MIKE PAGE: Hey, I'm Mike.
Head scientist at the
British Red Cross.
After agreeing to
redeploy into Matt's team,
I took a quick peek at the
repositories he had created,
excited to see what I
might be working on.
My reaction was,
of course, panic.
What I thought was going to
be a project in its infancy,
had already morphed
into thousands
of lines of code, split
across hundreds of files,
data sets, repositories.
Add to this the pressure
of a pandemic, and the need
to develop rapidly, I wondered
what I got myself into.
Thankfully, I was soon to learn
that these feelings of panic
were unfounded.
The project had a silent hero
working in the background,
allowing me to quickly
get up to speed.
This hero was the Tidyverse.
So, why the Tidyverse?
Every data size problem
presents a unique landscape,
which must be navigated.
Here the British Red Cross, we
like to think of the Tidyverse
as a cognitive superhighway
for many of these landscapes.
The signs are clear
and easy to follow.
And it's easy to
show colleagues,
and your future self, how to
navigate through the terrain.
But, this is not to say
the Tidyverse is always
the correct path to
take for every problem.
Depending on the task at hand,
other tools and paradigms
may be better suited, such
as pandas and datatable.
However, at the
British Red Cross,
we often have a requirement
to develop and collaborate
quickly.
And this is why we believe the
Tidyverse shines most brightly.
It quickly allows us to
translate our ideas to code.
This is because the
unifying design principles
of the Tidyverse are
centered first and foremost
around cognitive performance,
not computational performance.
To demonstrate why
this is important,
I'm going to show
you some example
code snippets from the
vulnerability index Matt
introduced earlier.
For each snippet,
I'll demonstrate
how the unifying
principles of the Tidyverse
made development
quicker and easier,
allowing us to respond rapidly
to the emerging pandemic.
First, let's take a look at the
human-centered and inclusive
principles.
Together, they acknowledge
that data scientists
come in all shapes and sizes.
This means the Tidyverse
APIs and documentation
are designed to be
read and written
by everyone, irrespective
of their background.
This means it's not just for
computer science graduates,
whose idea of a fun
weekend is arguing about
whether a raise should
be zero or one indexed.
This quote from the Tidyverse
design principles book
sums up the human-inclusive
principles nicely.
"One particularly powerful
idea is that of affordance.
The exterior of a tools
should suggest how to use it."
For example, take a look at this
code snippet, written by Matt,
that calculates a mean total
response time from the fire
and rescue authorities, using
a classic dplyr style pipeline.
Without ever having seen the
code, and only a little bit
of prior Tidyverse
knowledge, it's quick to read
and intuitive to understand
what is going on.
Take the fire and
rescue authority stats.
Filter only for fires
in English dwellings.
And create a new
variable, called "year."
So, it's only the
variables of interest.
And, finally, group
by geographical
variable to find the average
three-year fire and rescue
response time in a given area.
The code almost reads
like English prose,
listing off a set of
clear instructions.
There's no
requirements to reason
about things the
computer's optimized to do,
such as indexing and subsetting.
The result is code that
is quicker to write, read,
and collaborate on.
Another important design
principle of the Tidyverse
is that of consistency.
Principally, this
idea means finding
the smallest possible
set of key ideas,
and using them again and again.
This manifests itself in
two ways in the Tidyverse,
in its structures
and function APIs.
The code snippet
I'm about to show
demonstrates the power
of this idea effectively.
This code generates a
dataframe of weights,
across four domains of
vulnerability, where only two
domains should be weighted
at any given time,
and the sum of the
weights must equal one.
The main power of the snippet
lies in the first function,
crossing, which generates
all combinations of variables
found in the data set, while
duplicating and sorting
the inputs.
Here, the yellow arrows
demonstrate the consistent Tidy
dataframe structures used
throughout this example.
Using one common data
structure over and over again,
reduced the cognitive
load required
to reason about the problem
we were challenged with.
One reason for this is that
the consistent data structures
mean the APIs of the Tidyverse
communicate seamlessly.
For example, we
can see, here, how
the functions from tidyr and
bplyr fit together like a box.
This mostly removes
the need to reason
about the input and
output structure
of the data being passed
throughout of this Tidyverse,
making it quick to learn new
tidy functions and packages.
Consistency also extends
to the naming of functions
throughout the Tidyverse.
In general, Tidyverse
function names
offer imperative
verbs over nouns,
long names over short
names, and thematic unity
between similar
groups of functions.
The end result
are functions that
easy to remember and implement.
This particular code snippet,
I recall a deep sense of joy,
as I intuitively knew
the name of the functions
I needed to recall, despite
only using several of them
a handful of times.
The final design
principle of the Tidyverse
is that it should be composable.
This means a complex
problems to be
solved by combining
many small pieces,
with each small piece
easy to reason about.
This is realized
in the Tidyverse
for a predominant functional
programming paradigm,
that uses immutable objects.
This means problems are solved
by combining functions that
transform data, rather
than by creating objects
whose state changes over time.
We saw the power of
this, idea previously,
where a consistent,
immutable Tidy dataframe
object was used, throughout.
This long codeblock demonstrates
the idea of compatibility,
nicely.
Try not to be drawn in to
immediately understand it.
Instead, notice how many
small pieces of the tiny bits
are used to solve an overall,
more complex problem.
In some instances, some
functions, such as mutate,
are used over and over again.
The end result is we are able
to solve complex problems more
quickly.
And this particular
case allowed us
to assess the vulnerability of
different regions of the UK,
split across different
vulnerabilities
of the vulnerability index.
So, let's turn back
to Matt and find out
how these design principles
have impacted our response
to the COVID-19 pandemic.
MATT THOMAS: Have you noticed
how all the principals
are linked together?
The Tidyverse
principals are rooted
in cognitive theories of mind.
And they make it easy for
humans, like me and Mike,
to pull insights
out of data sets
and make new tools for people.
One example of how we've
used our vulnerability index
to design better
services for people
is our COVID-19 hardship fund.
Aviva, an insurance company,
donated five million pounds
to us, to give to people who
are facing economic hardship
during the pandemic.
We used our vulnerability
index, alongside other research,
to figure out that
the people most
likely to need financial support
included those without access
to state welfare, older
isolated people, people
facing homelessness or living
in temporary accommodation,
and survivors of
gender-based violence.
In one region of
England, this mapping,
combined with local intelligence
from our frontline teams,
led to more than half of
referrals to our hardship fund
coming from the most
vulnerable areas.
As of December 2020, we've
helped more than 7,000 people
with financial assistance.
So, following the
Tidyverse design
principles made it faster
for Mike and I, and others,
to get our ideas
out of our heads,
and translated into something
useful in the real world.
This cognitive speed
is really key for us,
working as a humanitarian
organization.
To put a spin on the
well-known agile phrase,
"We need to move
fast and save thing."
And we're not just
working with one another.
It is often said, your
most important collaborator
is yourself, six
months down the line.
Even if you don't use
the device itself,
we suggest using all
four design principles
as inspiration for future
package and code design.
Writing code and
packages in the future,
think about cognitive
performance.
Not only computational
For our work on the
vulnerability index,
this meant that there
hasn't been a single time
that Mike or I had to explain
our code to one another,
which is remarkable.
We should often be
writing code that
is human-centric and designed
around how people actually
think and work.
The key is to build tools
and analysis faster,
for real world impact.
Thank you for listening.